في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
موقع ريبار العسكريه الروسي ان معارك
وصفها بالشرسه ما تزال دائره وسط مدينه
باكموت بين قوه فاغنر والقوات الاوكرانيه
واضاف الموقع العسكري الروسي ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تزال موجوده في تحصينات
ومعاقل من بنايات ذات طوابق متعدده وانها
تلقى تعزيزات في الضواحي الغربيه للمدينه
واكد الموقع العسكري الروسي ان قوه فاغنر
تحقق بعض التقدم في مناطق سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه وتبسط سيطرتها على نحو 80% من
مدينه باخموت
في غضون ذلك كشف المتحدث باسم القوات
الشرقيه الاوكرانيه ان مدينه تتعرض لقصف
كثيف وان القوات الاوكرانيه لا تزال تدافع
عن المدينه وقال المسؤول العسكري
الاوكراني ان روسيا تنشر المزيد من القوات
المحموله جوا لدعم مقاتل فاجنر بسبب
خسائرها الفادحه في بخموت وكانت
الاستخبارات المبرطاليه قد اكدت في وقت
سابق ان القوات الاوكرانيه تواجه مشاكل
كبيره في عمليات الامداد ما اجبرها على
الانسحاب من بعض المناطق في بخمه